こんにちははじめ社長です今ですね私立やをしておりまして
昨日のお昼前に起きてから今ちょっと24時間を過ぎて今ちょうど夕方の4時ぐらいに
なろうとしておりますかな
すごいけだるいですねセットいやそういうことが多くてさ
だるくて眠くてうわぁっていう時があるんですけども僕はずっと体最適なことを考え
ましてまぁこのテンションで多分ね youtube の動画を撮っても面白いてない
のでそんな
鉄焼の湯つばにおすすめの面白い動画を撮る方法があります
なんと youtube の中ではある bg もつけると必ずこの道
これが面白くなるという禁断の bgm がありますこちらです
はいみなさん聞いたことがあるのではないでしょうかほど昔は乱用してたんですけど
結構もうね色んなユーチューバーが使ってますよ面白い大爆笑するべき場所でこれを
流すといけばなんかみんな大爆笑するだろうみたいなクリーンだけど実際 bgm が
なかったらそうでもないみたいなとても乱用される agm でございますでも
やっぱりこの bgm を使うとたいていのことは何でも面白く
見えるですこれは僕の経験からも言えることがあってたので今日は4度と彼はもう
が揃ってないですこんな増強でも多分さんの bg も使えば4なことだってても
面白く見えるんじゃねーかと思ったので
すべての動画面白くなるという噂を検証していきたいと思います酒に言うけど
本当になんともないこと少しないからでないという
tee
おっ
ん
えっ
バッ
bea
バーン
はぁん
あっはぁし
ん
音ございます
スプーン
pai
me
3月られるためだった
ran
bg
だーれだ
goo
ni